Here's another book for my grandkids called Matilda Brown.
One day, not very long ago, beside a quiet town, there was a woman rather large, her name
Matilda Brown.
Her home was just a cottage, crooked, chipped, and bent, with a porch made of cedar wood,
worn gray, and spent.
She baked every Monday a few brown loafs of bread, a white cake that she'd give to bless
someone, she said, a pie for her dessert after dinners for the week, a turkey that she'd
share with someone new that she would seek.
She looked not for a thank you, as her blessings she'd bestow, she just said, my debt was
paid so very long ago.
On Tuesdays, she'd sit and sketch with a pencil on her chair, as she rocked her mind
with water, and mentally prepare.
For this day she compiled a list of the ones that she would bless, for the postman, her
pastor, neighbor, or a stranger was best.
The evening was for writing cards, just to make one smile.
She would decorate them with antique lace, and put them in a pile.
One by one she blessed them with a prayer, for those who'd soon receive, a little piece
of heaven, to help them to believe.
She looked not for a thank you, as her blessings she'd bestow, she just said, my debt was paid
so very long ago.
For on Wednesdays she'd travel, with a cane in one hand, at her bag filled with trickets
she'd wrapped with a band.
Some cards of thanksgiving, a sandwich or two, homemade angels of popsicle sticks held
with glue, some leftover cookies on plates wrapped in foil, white cake, now frosted, and
six colored eggs, hard boiled.
Distributing treasures on Wednesdays, she'd say, was where I was most blessed when I gave
away.
She looked not for a thank you, as her blessings she'd bestow, she just said, my debt was paid
so very long ago.
Thursdays you'd think she'd be tired of her tolls, but the woman woke early to gather some
bowls.
She filled them half full with some cream, mix some milk mixed with cream, then she put on
her apron that was stained at the seam.
Now carefully placing the bowls on a tray she paused, bowed her head and thankfully prayed.
With both wrinkled hands and a shake in her step, she carried those meals made for strays
with some pep.
She kicked the screen door open, crossed the porch, down the stairs, passed the path to the
shed where she once kept the mirrors, set, she set each separate bowl with precision and
love for a hungry young kitten she was sent from above.
She coaxed them with breakfast, each Thursday they'd say, and hopes to save one from the fate
of a stray.
She looked not for a thank you as her blessings she'd bestow, she just said, my debt was paid
so very long ago.
Fridays she would walk the 12 blocks into town where the animal shelter took her rescued
on down by the bus to the metro where people would pay for the kiddies and puppies they'd
bring there that day.
In a way she was a savior to that gentle lot who knew little of their dangers nor of her
protective plot.
She was said that Fridays were her favorite day for reminded her of just what her savior
had paid.
She looked not for a thank you as her blessings she'd bestow, she just said, my debt was paid
so very long ago.
Saturdays were days of rest for many in the town, but as you'd guess our kind old friend didn't
let that get her down.
She woke it down to hit the market before the sun was hot and pipped the freshest vegetables
to boil in a pot.
At home she'd add the chicken, carrots, beans and rice, then while she'd make some buns
it cooked and she'd add her secret spice.
As she invited special guests some people in the know, no there were others in her mind
and she was sure they'd show.
But always done she mustered up a will too strong to ignore and loved that giant pot of
soup across the kitchen floor.
She kicked the screen door open across the porch down the stairs, passed the path to the
shed where she once kept the mayors.
She placed the pot of blessings on a stump just perfect height, then begged to call the passers-by
to come taste her delight.
She fed the children down the block whose daddy had no work.
She fed the couple on their walk though it was just a perk.
She fed a little puppy, a man from out of town and others that had need came, for word
had spread around.
Some took as if expected.
Some thanked her with a smile, some needed it so badly, others stayed to talk a while.
She looked not for a thank you as her blessings she'd bestow.
She just said my dad was paid so very long ago.
Sunday was a day of rest after church was done.
There she attended Bible school and learned about such fun.
She smiled as new ideas would pop into her head.
She learned of how to be a blessing from the master as she read.
Some others talked about her as they chatted about the town.
I heard a young girl say once, I want to be like until the brown.
If Mrs. Brown could hear she'd smile and tell her, lassie as you grow, just remember that
your dad was paid so very long ago.